partir en allemagne ce jeune homme de 20
ans qui en mai 87 avait posé son petit
avion sur la place rouge
le geste de moscou c'est aussi un
nouveau signe de détente de la part des
autorités soviétiques
la querelle de l'école de police
d'egletons en corrèze pierre joxe le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a annulé le
projet est l'invité de notre journal ce
à quoi pour la fermeture éclair pour la
troisième fois en sept ans est clair
presse il a de nouveau déposé son bilan
in fine de la concurrence fin de
carrière pour paco ojeda le plus grands
toreros de ces dix dernières années
arrête la corrida mais il se lance un
nouveau défi la corrida l'odyssée de
mathias roux était sur le point de
s'achever et leur a duré presqu'un an et
demi en ce moment-même mathias rouste
prend un autre avion
mais c'est pour revenir en ligne
régulière de moscou à francfort ce jeune
allemand de 20 ans s'était rendu célèbre
un jour de mai 87 en offrant au monde
entier l'image de l'année son petit
avion s'était posé sur la place rouge
après avoir déjoué toute la défense
aérienne soviétique résultats de
l'exploit le ministre soviétique de la
défense avait dû démissionner et pour
matière rouste quatre ans de prison
gilles rabin il est libre ce jeune
allemand timide qui il y à 11 mois jour
pour jour s'entendait condamné à quatre
ans de camp de travail par la cour
suprême de moscou quatre ans de camp
pour avoir ridiculisé la défense
aérienne et l'état-major soviétique tout
entier en posant son avion privé au bas
de la place rouge
mathias roux ce ne sera donc resté que
13 mois en prison 429 jours exactement
soulagement et satisfaction cet après
midi en allemagne de l'ouest dès la
nouvelle connue de sa libération
anticipée à hambourg d'abord dans l'aéro
club de mathias rouste
mon sentiment c'est qu'il risque
maintenant de servir de mauvais exemple
et qu'il fasse des émules enfin il est
libre tant mieux et je m'en réjouis bien
sûr déclare son ancien professeur de
pilotage la presse a siégé tout l'après
midi la maison de matthias rouste
mais ses parents se sont refusés à toute
déclaration le magazine allemand stern a
acheté depuis 13 mois l'exclusivité de
leurs paroles enfin l'homme par qui
cette mesure de grâce est sans doute
arrivée le ministre des affaires
étrangères ouest allemand hans dietrich
genscher
a voulu souligner que dans l'esprit de
mikhaïl gorbatchev qui l'a vu dimanche
cette mesure devait renforcer des
relations entre lurs et la rfa relations
qui doivent pour les soviétiques jouer
dorénavant un rôle clé on a tout dit de
mathias roast on a dit qu'il était un
espion à la solde de l'occident on a dit
aussi qu'il était un peu demeuré en fait
c'était seulement un fou volant dès
qu'il avait pu prendre les commandes
d'un avion
il n'avait plus penser qu'à sa volée
rappelle d'un exploit historique
pascal deschamps les badauds moscovite
ne croient pas leurs yeux
après avoir survolé les tours du kremlin
un frêle avions de tourisme se pose à
quelques mètres de la place rouge aux
commandes
matthias russ un jeune allemand timide
fou d'aviation
on s'interrogera longtemps sur les
raisons de son geste je voulais faire
quelque chose de grand dont tout le
monde parlera aurait-il dit c'est réussi
tout le monde en parle mais la
plaisanterie tournevis allègre pour
matthias russ d'abord qui a tout juste
le temps de signer quelques autographes
avant d'être arrêté son procès s'ouvre
le 2 septembre 1987 en présence de ses
parents qui leur voix pour la première
fois matthias russ qui risque alors huit
ans de détention plaide coupable
toujours plus tard le verdict tombe il
est condamné à quatre ans de camp de
travail pour hooliganisme aggravée
conséquence également pour l'armée rouge
ridiculisés par l'exploit du pilote
amateur qui a pu parvenir jusqu'à moscou
sans être interceptés mikhaïl gorbatchev
en profite pour limoger deux militaires
opposés à ces réformes
sergueï sokolov ministre de la défense
et le commandant de la force anti
aérienne alexandre coldenhoff sévère à
leur égard le premier secrétaire ne
pouvait pas en même temps
gracié le jeune condamnés une première
demande et donc racheté en décembre
dernier et la sphère rust tombe peu à
peu dans l'oubli
effectivement delà de l'anecdote
l'histoire de mathias rosstat eu des
prolongements à tous les niveaux de la
diplomatie et ce n'est pas hasard pierre
serra si sa libération intervient en ce
moment écoutez l'épopée de mahdia
through c'était à la fois ridicule et
grave pour les soviétiques ridicule
parce que en se posant sur la place
rouge au centre de moscou
il a réussi ce que nie napoleoni la
wehrmacht n'avait accompli est grave
parce qu'on vient de le dire
elle a donné lieu cette épopée à une
valse dans les chais les hauts
responsables militaires soviétiques
pratique au sida
bon alors le moment choisi n'est pas dû
au hasard c'est vrai d'abord garder
mater matthias russ est en prison
c'était peut-être perpétuer le ridicule
et puis ensuite dans les conditions
actuelles ce qui est valable maintenant
c'est que les soviétiques ont dû penser
que maintenant il n'y avait pas de
pression apparente pour le faire libérer
tout d'un coup donc le bon était
peut-être venu que finalement on pouvait
se dire que l'affront est lavé
aujourd'hui c'est ça et puis dans les
conditions actuelles dans la glace noces
de la transparence qu'est-ce qui a
risqué mais il se fait c'est partout la
transparence donc aujourd'hui on peut
penser que après que hier notamment une
armée rouge assez rétive pour pratiquer
la transparence avait montré au ministre
américain de la défense carlucci son
avion le plus secret bien aujourd'hui
vous pouvez lire mathias roux ça lorsque
vous faut comprendre c'est que le
kremlin est à l'aise cette conclusion il
avait 13 ans pour comprendre que
matthias russ devait finalement une
aventure il aventures comiques aux
militaires et qui avait 13 voix pour le
comprendre
treize mois pendant lesquels va mater a
soutenu attendent derrière ses barreaux
merci pierre la nouvelle calédonie où
l'on reparle d'un voyage de michel
rocard dans le territoire en fait on en
parle depuis les accords de matignon ce
voyage est probable mais tout dépend en
réalité des discussions qui ont lieu en
ce moment sur place dans le territoire
alors où en est on rachid arhab michel
rocard toujours en vacances les
collaborateurs du premier ministre garde
la maison et prépare notamment le voyage
du chef du gouvernement
en nouvelle calédonie un voyage qui
pourrait se dérouler vers la mi-août
c'est michel rocard lui-même qui prendra
la décision définitive la semaine
prochaine certainement en fonction de
l'avancée des discussions
en lieu en ce moment à nouméa autour du
haut-commissaire père la crasse et on
sait que les indépendantistes ont fait
de nouvelles propositions gouvernement
on sait aussi qu'une nouvelle rencontre
âpre et serrée fait une caresse était
prévue à paris vers le 10 août
mais du côté indépendantiste on affirme
que ce nouvel aller retour à paris est
conditionné par l'accueil qui sera
réservé à leurs nouvelles propositions
pour contourner la difficulté à matignon
on se déclare donc prêt à discuter sur
place michel rocard louis le pensec et
d'autres ministres seront donc très
certainement en nouvelle calédonie une
façon de dire aux effets mks si tu ne
viens pas à matignon
matignon ira à toi la polémique des
gueuletons il y avait pour l'instant le
discours des gloutons il ya maintenant
la querelle de l'école de police à
egletons c'est une petite ville de
corrèze le département de jacques chirac
où devait être créé une école de police
justement pierre joxe le nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur a décidé
d'annuler le projet chirac mécontents
proteste leurs ambitions 120 millions
d'investissements de 100 emplois
permanents et une centaine de logements
qui partent en fumée à egletons la
décision de pierre joxe de ne pas
construire l'école de police promise par
jacques chirac et dont les travaux
devaient commencer le mois dernier et
ressenti avec amertume malgré une
dizaine de réunions d'experts et des
contrats déjà signés avec des
entreprises de travaux publics
le ministre de l'intérieur a jugé le
projet egletons complètement dépassé il
s'agit aujourd'hui de créer des centres
de formation polyvalent ouvert aux
différentes catégories de policiers
alors que l'école d'egletons pour et
était spécialisé dans la formation des
appelés du contingent autres arguments
du ministre de l'intérieur une petite
ville de 6000 habitants où la
délinquance est pratiquement inexistante
n'est pas l'endroit idéal pour apprendre
aux policiers à évoluer en milieu urbain
à lutter contre la criminalité ou à
régler un gros bouchon à six heures du
soir mauvais argument réplique tankers
l'ensemble des élus corréziens qui
jacques chirac en tête demandent au
ministre de l'intérieur de revenir sur
sa décision
pour l'ancien premier ministre qui a
écrit à pierre joxe les arguments
avancés n'ont aucune valeur technique et
masquer une volonté sectaire de nuire à
la corrèze arguments des uns contre
arguments des autres la bataille des
gloutons a déjà dépassé le cadre loc
al pour devenir une affaire politique
avec nos pierre joxe le ministre de
l'intérieur bonsoir monsieur le ministre
alors c'est vraiment pour embêter
jacques chirac que vous avez vous avait
annulé ce projet d'égletons pourquoi
aurais-je la volonté de nuire à la
corrèze d'abord il n'y a pas de
polémique pour une polémique il faut
être au moins deux pour ce qui me
concerne je n'ai pas à polémiquer
monsieur chirac on va construire
plusieurs écoles de police dans les
années qui viennent
et dès l'année prochaine tout ça dans
des villes pourquoi pour former des
policiers qui ont à apprendre leur
métier ou des jeunes du contingent qui
font leur service national avec beaucoup
de succès dans des villes alors à paris
je veux en faire non pas une ni deux
mais trois et le maire de paris fait
monsieur chirac qui est aussi député de
la corrèze va voir que je n'ai pas non
plus la volonté de nuire de façon
secteur à paris et va m'aider chirac
pour construire plusieurs écoles de
police à paris et je le souhaite vu le
voir le 19 août à préfecture de police à
une cérémonie traditionnelle
on va pouvoir parler ensemble et le
maire de paris sera content l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il est
comprendra parfaitement que les français
comprendront aussi qu'on ne va pas
construire une école pour former des
fonctionnaires de police dans une
bourgade qui a l'air très joli on peut
faire d'autre ricol à egletons pas pour
former des gardiens de la paix alors
vous êtes donc effectivement lise de la
police votre prédécesseur charles pasqua
était très populaire dix ans parmi les
policiers
une succession difficile ah je sais pas
je regardais jamais de sondages parmi
les policiers vous savez ce que je
souhaite qu'ils obéissent alors tout à
l'heure un seul registre on parlait de
la nouvelle calédonie il y aura
peut-être un référendum peut-être pas
c'est pour septembre en principe vous le
préparez déjà le référendum soit la
nouvelle calédonie c'est le moment où
les français et les françaises pourront
dire oui nous approuvons l'accord
politique que le premier ministre
monsieur rocard a élaboré il ya quelques
semaines on ne peut pas soumettre à
référendum tant que cet accord n'est pas
définitif dûment authentifiés et prendra
la forme d'un projet de loi les français
vont devenir législateur se sera pas les
députés qui vont hanter la loi ce sont
les français les françaises
on refera le référendum dès que ce sera
politiquement possible j'espère que ce
sera bientôt
c'est à dire que vous avez l'impression
que le processus de paix engagé en
nouvelle calédonie est bien engagé
justement on va écouter façon ce que je
constate c'est que monsieur lafleur et
chibaou que je connais tous les deux que
j'ai rencontré à paris tous les deux
après un appel les accords de matignon
avait l'air d'un homme heureux d'avoir
réussi à tomber d'accord sur des
orientations qui donnait une garantie de
paix en nouvelle calédonie je pense que
c'est normal il ya beaucoup de problèmes
à régler parfois dans les détails y
compris sur le plan juridique
géographique mais après ce que j'ai vu
ce que j'ai entendu deux je suis très
confiant s'il y un référendum en
septembre qui serait couplé avec les
cantonales ça ferait si scrutin dans
l'année législative président
présidentiel législatif cantonal
référendum c'est beaucoup non
c'est beaucoup et d'ailleurs plusieurs
penser qu'il faudrait regrouper les
élections locales par exemple les
élections cantonales élections
municipales qui auront lieu cet automne
ou au printemps prochain et puis l'année
d'après et encore d'autres
moi je pense que si les parlementaires
si des élus proposent des mesures de
regroupement des élections en
particulier des élections locales
départementales municipales régionales
et bien le gouvernement pourrait prendre
les mesures pour se sont ensuite voté
par la loi je pense que ça devrait venir
des élus si ça vient du gouvernement
mais hier c'est une manoeuvre politique
tout le monde en parle personne ne le
propose que les élus le propose je suis
sûr que le premier ministre sera
d'accord avec cette erreur je fais créé
le calme le plus plat dans le domaine
politique
mais tout de même la rentrée c'est très
bientôt monsieur jacques cette rentrée
vous la voyez sous le signe de
l'ouverture alors c'est le plus calme le
plus plat dans le domaine politique
c'est normal c'est l'été c'est pas le
cas le plus plat dans le domaine
administratif
il ya beaucoup de services publics qui
fonctionnent pas seulement la police ou
disent que je chef de la police le jeu
si seulement bien sûr et aussi dans le
domaine de la sécurité en général de la
sécurité routière à sepa calme les
français recommence à conduire comme des
fous et la france cette année je voulais
déjà dit moment de la pentecôte est en
train de confirmer si on continue comme
ça le triste record d'être le pays du
monde où proportionnellement il
le plus d'accidents mortels une fois de
plus vous verrez que chacun prenne
conscience que il n'est pas normal il
est lamentable que la france détient ce
record et il reste encore tout le mois
d'août
les retours de septembre pour éviter
qu'on arrive à cette catastrophe
on en est émue chaque fois qu'il ya une
grande catastrophe ferroviaire par
exemple avec des dizaines de morts mais
à weekend avec 3 d'imprudence c'est une
grande catastrophe routière
voilà sur ce plan ce n'est pas calme
c'est vrai nous en avons parlé souvent
dans les journaux janvier nous le
faisons plus souvent possible joliette
sur cette question politique la rentrée
vous la voyez sous le signe de
l'ouverture à écoute là les départs en
vacances s'est fait sous steam
l'ouverture le gouvernement a été
constitué sur des bases je crois qu'il
montrait une volonté de large
coopération de rassemblement autour des
idées du président de la république
réseau république a été élu sur le thème
était la france unie beaucoup d'idées
derrière la france unie c'est un thème
que les français ont approuvé la
composition du gouvernement
la politique que nous voulons mettre en
oeuvre s'inspire des bonnes idées
c'est monsieur joxe vous étiez vous avez
toujours été considéré comme un dur du
parti socialiste alors l'ouverture ça
vous gêne pas du tout qu'il faut pas des
durs pour faire l'ouverture
dernière question pierre joxe très
courte vous allez voir c'est à propos
les machines à sous
charles pasqua avait autorisé les
machines à sous dans les casinos il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont en vacances a
beaucoup de succès d'ailleurs vous êtes
pour vous d'être content c'est une loi
qui a autorisé en france c'est pas
monsieur pasqua monsieur pasqua
voilà il a fait voter une loi c'est une
loi que nous avons combattu c'est une
mauvaise voie mais je l'appliqué moi
j'applique la loi toute la loi rien que
la loi dans le même des juges mon
prédécesseur qui était mon successeur
monsieur pasqua avait une pratique
différente de la mienne
tout le monde l'a remarqué je reviens je
reprends la même pratique qui est
d'ailleurs celle qu'avait d'autres
ministre de l'intérieur que monsieur
bonnet monsieur marc cela je crois que
les français comprennent parfaitement
qu'en matière de jeu un peu de rigueur
est nécessaire merci pierre joxe
merci monsieur le ministre le reste de
l'actualité tout de suite l'économie
d'abord les difficultés de la fermeture
éclair
11 tout à fait de sujets elle a bercé
toute notre enfance ce n'est pas une
blague les éclairs presse-t-il ferme ou
tout au moins dépose son bilan pour la
troisième fois en sept ans ce n'est pas
que le bouton prend sa revanche
vous allez le voir ce sont les
fabricants étrangers de fermeture à
glissière qui sont de plus en plus
performants il ne respecte rien n'aime
pas nos souvenirs d'enfance mbt
etes-vous fermeture éclair ou bouton
certains croient voir là dans le
renouveau du boutons de braguette la
raison des difficultés de la société est
clair presse-t-il l'explication est
pourtant ailleurs des fermetures à
glissière on continue d'en vendre par
kilomètre mais ce ne sont pas des
fermetures éclair est un produit trop
cher pour notre consommation
les confectionneurs maintenant ne
recherche plus la qualité recherche le
produit très bon marché et
malheureusement nous sommes nous sommes
obligés d'acheter à taïwan le produit à
50 à 60% moins cher que l'aspect naturel
qu'est le concurrent principal de la
fermeture éclair c'est le japonais y
kaka est clair prestige ne détient plus
aujourd'hui que 30 % du marché contre
60% il ya 20 ans le déficit devient
chronique 40 millions de francs chaque
année à près d'un premier dépôt de bilan
en 1982 rien n'y a fait ni quatre plans
de restructurations successives ni des
subventions massives de l'état
il a été procédé à des licenciements
puisque l'entreprise à l'époque pour
1982 employés 1800 personnes
mais on a laissé subsister à certain
nombre d'emplois qui ont entraîné des
coûts plus élevés que ceux auxquels
l'entreprise peau et faire face et d'une
certaine mesure on peut dire que les
subventions de l'état ont davantage été
utilisé à payer cette perte qu'à
investir et à créer des moyens de
production nouveau et peut-être même les
emplois nouveaux
la société est clair précis il attend un
repreneur le géant du textile
britannique oates est sur les rangs un
nouvel effort du commerce mondial fait
le résultat d'une enquête du gatt les
échanges internationaux se porte bien et
la france est toujours quatrième
exportateur dans le monde même si les
français ventes à l'étranger deux fois
moins que les allemands qui sont les
champions de l'exportation pour réussir
l'exportation il faut de l'imagination
et quelques vieilles recettes regarder
ce que ces français ont fait en extrême
orient
ils leur ont vendu du pain reportage
jean pierre métivier c'est coustilles
ans et la dernière fringale des gens de
pékin dans la capitale chinoise
une cinquantaine de dépôt semblable à
celui ci propose petits pains croissants
et les inévitables bâtard français il
s'en vend 14 milles par jour
mais ce n'est pas encore la révolution
dans les habitudes alimentaires
à l'origine de cette initiative
les grands moulins de paris ils sont
surpris du succès
la boulangerie où tous les employés sont
chinois n'arrive même plus à satisfaire
à la demande
après un an d'existence elle doit déjà
penser à s'agrandir des combats
pourtant le pain français est déjà connu
des échecs cuisants ici et même un
véritable four
voici trois ans lorsqu'un premier
ministre chinois a voulu convertir ses
compatriotes à la baguette française
le secrétaire général du parti de
l'époque monsieur croyante ban avait
estimé que le pain avait été un élément
de croissance à l'occident il s'est
rendu compte qu'en chine ont pas d
beaucoup de temps à midi pour retourner
à la maison faire cuire le riz
il fallait deux servent à peu près alors
qu'en occident très souvent les sociétés
ne s'arrêtent pas entre midi et deux
elle avait donc encourager les chinois à
changer leur mode de consommation et à
se mettre au pas à la place du ring
résultat du pain perdu vendu dans les
hôtels pour étrangers à l'époque le pain
blanc rouge pas patienter à des milliers
de kilomètres de la chine
ici à singapour on ya créé des fast food
à la française en n'hésitant pas pour
forcer le succès à fismes hanter le goût
des produits
produit quand le cayor moitié foule
des produits à bas le shipping curie ils
sont des produits en pleine influence
cuisinière et l'on sert actuellement
et j'avoue que c'est un peu notre
c'est de s'adapter et d'attirer les gens
parlent des couples connaissent déjà
curieux les industriels s'échine à
décrocher de gros contrats au bout du
monde et les boulangers français
grignote lentement le marché asiatique
avec un produit à la plus-value
dérisoire la baguette de sang soo
le tgv nord ce sera un tracé direct
paris lille le gouvernement a décidé de
maintenir le tracé prévu le tgv ne
passera donc pas à amiens comme le
réclamaient les habitants de cette
région
je vous propose maintenant de voir les
principales informations à l'étranger
avec claude crespo quatre passagers
tuées et 16 blessées dans le
déraillement de cette navette oviedo
santander dans le nord de l'espagne
les pluies de ces derniers jours ont
recouvert la voie d'une couche de boue
un virage un wagon se retourne un second
sort des rails il y avait 55 voyageurs
dans ce train
un soldat de l'armée britannique tués à
bord de son véhicule ce matin accoups
tarn à 60 km de belfast en irlande du
nord
un attentat signé quelques heures plus
tard par l'ira l'armée républicaine
irlandaise
la veille déjà l'organisation terroriste
revendiqué deux embuscades ou trois
membres des forces de sécurité on le
trouvait la mort
confirmation des condamnations à mort
pour les deux sites qui le 31 octobre 84
ont tué madame gandhi les juges ont
relaxé le troisième condamné cet ex
policier qui a été aussitôt libéré pour
les autres un garde du corps et son
complice la grâce est maintenant entre
les mains du président indien
contre attaque soviétique pour dégager
kaboul la capitale afghane est depuis
deux semaines la cible des roquettes de
la résistance moudjahidine les
soviétiques épaulées par l'armée afghane
et par les miliciens se battent dans un
rayon de 50 km autour de kaboul
il faut ajouter encore les troubles en
birmanie la loi martiale a été décrétée
aujourd'hui à rangoon la capitale de la
birmanie il y aurait eu des
affrontements violents
et puis l'afrique australe est le
problème de l'angola depuis plusieurs
semaines les différentes parties
impliquées dans ce conflit tentent de
parvenir à un compromis c'est difficile
hier l'afrique du sud a fait des
propositions qui ont été immédiatement
rejetées par l'angola et par cuba qui a
une présence militaire très active dans
ce conflit
jérôme baugnies cessez le feu dès le 10
août prochain retrait total des troupes
sud-africaine d'angola le 1er septembre
élections dans une namibie indépendante
en juin 89
les propositions spectaculaire du
ministre des affaires étrangères sud
africain ont eu pour effet de donner un
coup de fouet aux négociations pour la
paix en angola qui ont repris hier à
genève
double objectif de ces négociations le
retrait et quelques 45 mille cube basée
en angola où ils soutiennent le régime
du président dos santos contre l'unita
le mouvement de guérilla de jonas
savimbi soutenu lui par pretoria
d'autre part l'évacuation du sud de
l'angola et de la namibie par l'afrique
du sud qui occupe ce pays au mépris de
la résolution 435 de l'onu votée il y a
dix ans une occupation contesté à
l'extérieur mais aussi à l'intérieur par
exemple par ces conscrits refusant de
servir dans l'armée sud africaine par
cette proposition d' accélération du
retrait des troupes étrangères d'afrique
australe le gouvernement de pretoria se
pose en champion de la paix et met la
balle dans le camp des angolais et des
cubes une contre-proposition aurait été
faite cet après midi à genève
mais cuba semble pour l'instant
favorable à un délai de trois ou quatre
ans pour le retrait de son propre
contingent
les discussions risquent donc d'être
encore longue
sur le calendrier de retrait des troupes
étrangères d'afrique du sud ouest pour
l'afghanistan elle ont duré quatre ans
la fin d'une époque pour tous les
aficionados paco ojeda la superbe
des corridas j'aurais bien dit le
champion mais il paraît que c'est un
terme qu'on n'emploie pas pour la
corrida bref paco ojeda quitte l'arène
il pourrait peut-être se consacrer une
autre discipline
portrait de la star et révélations
exclusives michel mompontet les
aficionado parler de lui comment parle
d'un peintre d'un sculpteur ou d'un
danseur les qualificatifs et elles mêmes
inventif courageux élégant unique la
magie extraordinaire de ces après midi
est désormais ancré dans les mémoires
dans le passé paco ojeda cesse
brutalement sa carrière dix ans qui
auront bouleversé toutes les conceptions
de l'art taurin désormais ces cinq
heures de l'après-midi à lui seront
paisibles la boule qu'il avait dans
l'estomac et qui l'accompagné depuis le
début la sûrement ce soir abandonné mais
le véritable endroit ou paco ojeda s'est
toujours sentie libre heureux c'est ici
dans les marais du guadalquivir
seuls les palaces l'ennuyer les amis
découvert avec la gloire le décevez la
critique espagnole qui se croyait
savante le blesser l'a complètement
révolutionné l'art de port et et la
danse comme toujours dans pareil cas
lorsqu il y a jenny quelqu'un qui
innovent les avis se partagent ils y
allaient supporter inconditionnel et la
critique parfois très dures et injustes
envers paco ojeda
paco ojeda a donc tout abandonner le
bruit les photographes la gloire et les
palaces pour le silence et démarrer seul
comme au début et sans illusion i 6 à 14
ans la nuit tombée il torée en cachette
dans ces immensités et rêver alors de
devenir une vedette
aujourd'hui il a repris ses longues
balades à cheval libre sur les côtes de
son andalousie
rêvons peut-être de devenir demain le
plus grands toreros les à cheval cette
fois ci à séville
on dit que seuls les rêves sont vérité
demain il ya un tiercé quarté c'est à
deauville là c'est même le premier tir
fait de la saison à deauville voici les
pronostics de pierrette brès le 3 le 14
le 2 le 12 le 18 le 9 le 10 et le 5 fans
ce journal dans quelques instants sophie
davant pour une météo plus optimistes
vous allez le voir le dernier journal la
dernière édition ce sera vers 23h30 avec
au brier de l'air à demain excellente
soirée sur antenne 2
non
à